[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi and
welcome to episode 107
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing
this morning, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Good morning, Mark.
It's nice and early where I am.
But where are you?
MARK MANDEL: How early
is it where you are?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
What is it?
Well, it's actually
almost 7:00 AM.
It just feels really early
when it's still dark.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty early.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where
are you at today?
MARK MANDEL: I am currently
in the Google Montreal office.
It's almost 10:00
here in the morning.
So it's not as early
for me as it is for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Exactly.
I'm back in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah.
This week, we have the band
back together, so to speak.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did.
We got the band
back together, just
in time for the end of
the year, to do a wrap up
of all the things.
It was a really good interview,
actually, to take Francesc back
into the recording
studio and we also
got our director, Greg
Wilson, to join us
as well to give his insights.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And to follow on
from that, this week,
we're going to have a
question of the week.
It's, what have been
your highlights for 2017?
What have been your
favorite things?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
We'll give a nice,
little highlight
for how our year went.
And before all of that, of
course, we need to jump into,
what are the cool
things of the week?
And these are the
last cool things
of the week that we'll have for
the year, which we were just
chatting about when we
were pulling them together,
because we have all the
things we want to talk about.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I tell you what, you
just came back from NIPS
and you have a bunch of stuff
around machine learning.
Why don't you get
stuck into that?
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
I just wanted to
highlight a few things,
in terms of the fact that
there were a number of really
great speakers.
I've actually posted this
on my Twitter account,
that most of the content
was actually recorded,
and is online, and there's
links for that, which
we can also share on our blog.
But there was a talk that
was given by Jeff Dean.
And his talk was
titled, Machine Learning
for Systems and Systems
for Machine Learning.
And part of it references some
of the work that's been done
and the success
stories that they've
had around the TPUs
version 2, as well as
how they're applying things
like reinforcement learning
to help with device placement.
And they recently
released a paper
that actually shows how
they're using indexes
and, specifically, machine learn
indexes that can replace things
like B-Trees, and Hash-Indexes,
and Bloom-Filters.
I believe that may have
been recorded and posted.
And if we can find out, we
will definitely share it.
Otherwise, we'll definitely
share the link for the paper.
And one other thing I want to
give a shout out to-- the fact
that Fei-Fei Li, who's the chief
scientist, of Cloud AI and ML
spoke.
And she gave some
insights, in terms
of some of her recent
work around machine
learning as it
applies to health.
Also something that, if we
can locate any kind of slides
from that, we'll
definitely share it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Yeah.
So continuing on the
machine learning path,
there's a new open source
project called Kubeflow.
I can talk about
the Kubernetes part,
you can talk about the
machine learning part.
I think that
probably works well.
So it's a project dedicated
to making machine learning
on Kubernetes easy,
portable, and scalable,
which I think is kind of cool.
It's basically
based on Kubernetes
and does machine
learning things.
I don't know about the
machine learning part,
do you know anything
about it, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know that it helps
make machine learning easier.
That's pretty much
what I know right now.
But yeah.
People should definitely
check that out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So definitely check
that out if you're
looking for a good, portable
way to do Kubernetes and machine
learning.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And we have a link
to the GitHub repo
for Kubeflow, as well
as we're going to share
a link for Y Combinator,
where there's some good content
and sharing of information
around that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Since we're on the
Kubernetes train,
I'll will bring up as
well-- there's a new tool.
MELANIE WARRICK: We never
get off the train, do we?
MARK MANDEL: I never
get off the train.
Someone was making fun of me on
Twitter about it the other day.
That was very funny.
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
Never.
MARK MANDEL: About how much I
like to talk about Kubernetes.
Because I do.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Of course, you do.
MARK MANDEL: If you're using
Kubernetes on us-- so GKE--
we just released a new
dashboard on cloud.google.com,
on the Cloud console,
that gives you
better introspection of what's
happening inside your cluster.
It's actually
fairly reminiscent,
if you've ever used
the dashboard UI that
comes built with Kubernetes.
But as we were talking
about last week,
you may necessarily want to turn
that off for security reasons.
But this still gives you a nice
visualization access to see
things like what
pods are running,
how much CPU they're using,
what services are available--
things like that--
access to logs directly,
all that kind of good stuff.
So if you haven't had a
look at cloud.google.com
and you've been running a GKE
cluster, have another look.
You might find the new
feature is kind of cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, I think that
covers it for what
we wanted to share for
cool things of the week.
And I think it;s time to go
ahead and get started with what
our interview/overview
of the year looks like.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
Let's go do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
So on today's podcast, I'm
here to welcome Greg Wilson,
who is our leader in charge,
and I've got Mark Mandel,
of course, who's my co-host,
and Francesc Campoy Flores--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Hello.
MELANIE WARRICK: Who
is our ex-Googler, who
has returned from the dead of
going off to another company.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Just for today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: I was actually
on holidays in
Brazil and Mexico.
So yeah, a really hard life.
MELANIE WARRICK: A hard life.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
What's it feel like,
wearing a guest badge today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: It is weird.
Yeah.
But there's still
access to food, so good.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
on today's podcast,
we wanted to, basically,
do a review of the year.
We're going to go back and look
back, over time, from the 2017,
and see what was our
favorites, and what was--
well, actually, we should
talk about what, maybe, are
some of the funny moments, too.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And Mark,
you should definitely
leave this off with, what are
some of the top five downloads?
Because you guys have been
here longer than I have.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
So first of all, thank you
very much to Greg and Francesc
for coming back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: It's
lovely to have you back.
We have the new people--
we have Melanie.
We have Francesc,
from the history.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: I thought you
were going to say old people.
I was like, dude.
MARK MANDEL: No,
that sounds good.
GREG WILSON: That's my job.
MARK MANDEL: Well, that's great.
So actually, first of all,
people who haven't met you,
Greg, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself
and what you do here,
at Google, as well?
You have a new
title now as well.
GREG WILSON: That's right.
So I'm director of developer
relations for Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: What
does that mean?
GREG WILSON: What
I'm still figuring that out,
after three and a half years.
So developer advocacy,
multiple developer programs,
developer programs,
engineering-- all the things
to make developers happy.
It reports up through our org.
MARK MANDEL: We're the
receptacle for your complaints.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are we happy?
Is this successful?
Apparently, it's successful,
if you were promoted.
So we do things like get
the word out at events.
This year, I think, this team
has done over 600 events--
going out, and
meeting developers
where they are, and let them
know what we're doing here.
We also do a lot of content.
We do a lot of driving
better developer experience
with the products.
We not only advocate
to the outside world
on behalf of Google, we
advocate to the product teams
on behalf of the outside
world, which, actually, I
think, we all take that part
of the job even more seriously.
So we have folks that
participate in open source
projects with Google, work
with the product teams
to improve the overall developer
experience of the platform.
MARK MANDEL: What are you
up to these days, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So
you're the director, I'm VP--
GREG WILSON: That's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Of developer relations.
GREG WILSON: There you go.
A double promo.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
But I'm the only person in
developer relations, too.
GREG WILSON: You
are your own boss.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
And also my own team.
But yeah.
So I left Google, as you
all know, one month ago.
November 1st was my
last day and also
my first day at the new company.
And I'm working for a
company called sourcesource[? d ?]..
And basically, what
we're trying to do
is apply machine
learning to source code
to build tools on top of that.
To do that, there's a lot
of infrastructure going on
and there's a lot of
tooling that needs to exist.
And we're working
immediately with those.
But then, also, we're working
with researchers and people
that are really, really good
on machine learning, which
I'm not, to build really
interesting tools.
There's a demo I'm
working on, which
is like do not re-invent
the wheel [INAUDIBLE]..
That tells you that the
code you're writing actually
looks a lot like something
that's on the library.
Use that function instead.
Things like that, which are not
really doable without machine
learning.
So it's really interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
That's a good problem
to be solving.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
It is very interesting.
And the good thing is
that it's also a platform,
like Google Cloud Platform.
So my job is still kind
of similar, in the way
that it's building
cool things to show
the power of a platform,
which means that you end up
building cool things.
So I'm having lots of fun.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm glad
you're having a good time.
And how does it feel to be back?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
It is really good.
It is weirdly familiar.
MELANIE WARRICK: Does it
feel like you ever left?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
I mean, I've been on every
episode until now, too, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
GREG WILSON: Well,
that's kind of sad.
MARK MANDEL: Now that
I think about it,
listeners will not
have missed you
because you haven't been gone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
OK.
Maybe we should not do these.
MARK MANDEL: Are you
still doing a lot with Go?
Are you still close to go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yes, I'm still doing Go,
I'm still doing JustForFunc.
All of the infrastructure on
the company is written in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
And there's packages
that they've open sourced.
That's actually how I
discovered the company--
Like [? 'go get', ?] which is
like the most used Git package
written in Go, it's
written by them.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So it's
still a lot of Go going on,
which I'm happy about.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Well, since we have
you here again,
Francesc and Greg, why
don't we go back in time?
MELANIE WARRICK: Back in time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Do we put in
sound effects right here?
The harp.
Where's our harp?
[HARP STRUMMING]
We go back in time.
And talk a little bit about
the inception of the podcast.
It's been two years.
We passed 100 episodes
together, which was fantastic.
Greg was there,
in the beginning.
Let's hear from
Greg's perspective.
I'm kind of curious.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
We know the story,
but what does he know?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Because, Francesc,
you and I, we sort of
sat down over a coffee one day.
And we were like, we
should do a podcast.
And then we came to Greg
and said, hey, Greg, we
think we might want to do a
podcast, what do you reckon?
GREG WILSON: And what's funny--
I found some slides from an
offsite that we did, as a team,
in 2015.
And one of the
slides in that was
that we need to find new
ways to reach our audiences.
And I gave examples.
And the second
example was podcast.
So because of that,
I'm taking full credit
for the entire podcast.
But anyway, the two
of you came to me
and proposed a podcast, which
I was super excited about.
But I distinctly remember
having a huge amount
of concern over your
proposal to do it weekly.
And I thought that
was absolutely insane.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: It was.
And I tried to talk you
out of it, I remember.
I said, weekly is
never going to work.
You guys will do like 12
episodes, and that will be fun,
and then it'll turn into
work, and then, by episode 20,
you're going to be out
of ideas, and telling me
you want to go
monthly or quarterly.
But I was absolutely
wrong on that,
I realized when you hit
episode 50 and now episode 100
and whatever.
It's really
incredibly impressive
how absolutely regular
you've kept it.
And you've kept it
exciting and fun.
So hats off to you guys.
It's pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
pretty excited also.
I just wanted to say that
Melanie's got some pretty cool
stuff lined up for next year.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
excited about that, too.
I'm looking forward to,
especially, the first episode.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
It's going to be awesome.
I'm super excited
Melanie joining.
When I first heard
Melanie was getting
involved in the podcast,
Mark and Francesc
were telling me a story of how--
I guess y'all were
having lunch together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
GREG WILSON: And just
having regular, Google, work
conversation around
various technical things,
and talking about
AI, and you were so
fascinated in Melanie's
description of it,
and her passion for it.
And you said, hey, let's go up
and record a podcast episode.
And so a few weeks later, when
Francesc made the decision
that he was going to
go try a new adventure,
it was like the obvious choice
because she was so good on it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's right.
I was born to do this.
GREG WILSON: Yeah, that's right.
It really just felt
completely natural.
Well, yeah.
Of course, she should
be the co-host.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
I think it was Mark that
said, maybe Melanie.
And my reaction was like,
oh, yeah, of course.
Yeah, absolutely.
And when we told you,
he was like, oh, yeah.
Of course, absolutely.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
It was like it was a no brainer.
Duh.
MARK MANDEL: I just want to
be clear-- there was no maybe
there.
It was, definitely Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh,
of course, you were.
I know.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're going to really
have a good time together.
GREG WILSON: So I'm
super excited about where
that's headed.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
super excited about where
that's headed as well.
And Greg, is this your
first time on the podcast?
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
I don't know how I was not able
to get myself in the podcast,
even though I stood outside the
door, and knocked, and begged--
please.
MELANIE WARRICK: We had to get
rid of Francesc, so that you
could come in the door.
GREG WILSON: That's right.
So now I know who
was blocking me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
So yeah, this is my
first time, but I
was excited to be a part of it.
I wanted to wait till
there was a certain traffic
level before I appeared.
MELANIE WARRICK: Before
you found it acceptable.
And now, after Vint
Cerf, you're like, yeah,
I think it's time for
me to get on there.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
OK.
If it's good enough for
Vint, good enough for me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Well with that
said, why don't we
go out and dive
into the top five
that we found that were very
popular within the community?
So actually, Mark,
Francesc, do you guys
want to jump into that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
So number five--
speaking of which--
GREG WILSON: Where's
the drum roll button?
[DRUM ROLL]
MARK MANDEL: Number
five is Vint Cerf.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That was an amazing episode.
MARK MANDEL: So if you're
going to listen to any episode,
I feel--
from the podcast-- you should
listen to that episode.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
I also have a recording of
our faces without the audio.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's hilarious.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
During that Hangout.
Because the conversation
was amazing,
but the subtext of the
conversation was even better.
At some point, Vint Cerf--
Mark asks that question.
And Vint Cerf goes, that's
a very good question.
And you could see that
Mark was incredibly happy.
It was the highlight
of his career,
getting, very good
question, from Vint Cerf.
That was amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Your
life has been perfect now.
You have nothing else
you need to achieve.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Vint Cerf thinks I
ask good questions.
So yeah, totally.
If you aren't
familiar with Vint,
he's one of the founders of
the internet-- basically,
the thing that
allows us to do this.
And still, my favorite
response of all time from him
is when asking him, hey,
you're building this brand new,
distributed network,
at the time,
did you think that
you were going
to change the world with
whatever this thing was
and how it was
going to come about?
And he was just like,
oh, yeah, totally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
He was very aware of that.
MELANIE WARRICK: How
did you guys get him?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I sent
him an email, going like, hey,
Vint Cerf, so we met a long
time ago at a cafe at Google.
This is a selfie
of the two of us.
And so I thought that we're
doing the "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast."
Without the internet
that you invented,
Google would not exists,
the Cloud would not exist,
and podcasts would not exist,
so it kind of makes sense
that you're the guest
for episode 100.
What do you think?
And he was like, OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So yeah.
I was like, amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Who knew how
valuable a selfie would be?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Oh, yeah.
GREG WILSON: Keep all selfies.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: You
should always take selfies.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Keep all the selfies.
So what did you like
most about the episode,
outside of the fact that you
were both extremely excited
and you have these great
videos of you watching it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I think
that the most amazing thing was
that we were asking
questions about what
we thought the future was
and he was mentioning--
for instance, we were
talking about like, well,
have you thought
about, in the future,
we'll need interplanetary
communications and things
like that?
Will TCP/IP be enough?
And he was like, oh, no.
No, it will not because
the ping is too big.
But we already solved
this with the JPL protocol
that we invented while
working with NASA.
I'm like, OK.
The future, for us, is something
that he has already considered
and, mostly, solved,
which was amazing.
It's the power of
predicting and, actually,
even adapting, before anything
happens, to the future
is just amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
What's number four?
MARK MANDEL: Number four
was Container Engine
with Chen Goldberg.
I've done a couple of
episodes with Chen.
She's pretty amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: She's
really, really, really good.
And that episode was really
good because it actually
helped us understand not only
what is Container Engine,
but what is the difference
between Container Engine
and Kubernetes, what is the
community, and things that.
MARK MANDEL: You know it's
now Kubernetes Engine, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Now
it's Kubernetes Engine--
that's true.
Yes.
Well, the title of the
episode is Container Engine.
MARK MANDEL: The title was
Container Engine-- that's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Which is good because now GKE
actually makes sense.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
what we were saying.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
It was a really good episode,
especially because she was also
talking about the community
and things like that.
So it was, from
a technical point
of view, really
interesting, but also, she's
a really good speaker.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, yeah.
One thing I really enjoyed
about that interview
was talking about
Google's involvement
in the open source process
of building this project that
involves multiple parties and
how all that sort of flows
together.
I thought that was
really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
Really, really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
what's number three?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Number three is--
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's all right.
We can skip that one.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
we can skip that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
It was episode 93--
What's AI?
With Melanie Warrick-- Warrick?
Yeah.
I've not heard about her.
Have you heard
about her, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
haven't heard about her.
MARK MANDEL: Melanie, what
was that episode about?
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: You can
probably tell us.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm not really sure.
I didn't listen to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: That's actually
the episode that
Greg was mentioning,
where we were having
lunch at Google
and decided that
this conversation is
really interesting, it
should be a podcast episode.
And we just made it
happen the same day.
MELANIE WARRICK: We did.
We were like, when
can we schedule this?
And I was like, now.
Let's do this now.
MARK MANDEL: So what is the
difference between AI and ML?
MELANIE WARRICK: There's
no difference-- no.
Listen to the podcast.
No.
The difference between AI
and ML, just for the record,
yes, ML is a set of algorithms
that are used to help with AI.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
What is the buzz word one?
Is it ML, AI, or is
there something else?
Is it deep learning?
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, the buzz
words are all the buzz words--
deep learning, AI, ML, big data.
All of it.
There's a lot of buzz words.
And it's used to make people
understand, really quickly,
what they're trying to talk
about without necessarily
having to dive too deep.
The reality is you need
to dive a little deeper.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: If you
want more of this, episode 93.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I know.
Exactly.
Check out episode 93.
All right.
So number two?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Episode 91--
The Future of Media with Machine
Learning with Amit Pande.
And this was really interesting
because I really did not
know what we were going into.
It was you, Mark, that
proposed the episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I saw Amit speak.
It was actually at
the New York Summit.
He did a presentation
on, basically,
practical applications
for machine learning
for the broadcast industry--
so film and television--
in a variety of circumstances,
especially including sports.
So this episode was
a really practical--
like this is how we
can use this thing now
to help people out when they
do broadcast television.
So automatic
highlights for sports
games, cameras that follow
interesting action that
happens--
things like that.
Yeah.
It was really, really,
really interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
it also, I believe,
talked about generating content,
too, which is interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Applications, in general,
is a constant question
in this space.
How are these algorithms
actually being
used in real world problems?
So it's valuable.
All right.
Last but not least, number one?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Number one--
of course, episode
88 with Tim Hockin
talking about Kubernetes 1.7.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I want to point
out one thing here,
which I think is kind of
interesting, that Kubernetes
shows up twice in our
top five, essentially.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
I mean, Kubernetes was basically
like 50% of our content,
I feel like.
In every episode, we've
talked about Kubernetes
in one way or the other.
MARK MANDEL: It's
probably my fault.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Questions of the week.
No.
Also, the people
use it for a lot.
MARK MANDEL: But
I think it kind of
does show the impact
of that project, which
is kind of interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think
there's two factors at play
here, with this
episode-- one, Kubernetes
is super cool and
interesting, people love it,
two, Everyone loves Tim Hockin.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Oh, yes.
It was really amazing how
it went on to Hacker News--
someone put it on Hacker News.
And it was the
first time that I've
seen people commenting
on Hacker News.
I mean, commenting not
really about the content--
that happens often--
but talking actually
about Tim, saying,
I just wanted to comment that
I know Tim Hockin from school
and he's an amazing guy.
Like people like
that, just saying
that he's an amazing
guy, in general.
And he is, really.
And the episode is
amazing because he
talks a little bit about what
is coming up and everything,
but also his involvement with
the project from the beginning
and stuff like that.
His point of view is
really, really important.
MARK MANDEL: He was
one of the founders.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
congratulations, Tim.
Well done.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice job.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
You won the year.
MELANIE WARRICK:
GREG WILSON: Could we send him
a new t-shirt or something?
MARK MANDEL: We probably should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I
think you said, a new t-shirt.
I don't think we
sent him a t-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: Sorry about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: We
should send him a t-shirt,
at some point.
MARK MANDEL: Or at
least some stickers.
I've got a lot of stickers.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
do you guys ever
send out t-shirts?
I don't think I got a t-shirt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: There's
a box downstairs, I think.
MARK MANDEL: I think it's empty.
I think we finished it all.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
So now that we've talked
about the popular ones based
on downloads, what are some of
the ones you enjoyed the most,
in terms of this year?
Greg?
GREG WILSON: I
always enjoy the ones
that bring real customers
into-- you know,
reaching outside of Google.
The customers.
So Niantic-- that episode,
I thought, was fantastic.
And plus, I had
a lot of interest
in how they were
using our platform
and how you scale something
of that magnitude.
Home Depot, Broad
Institute-- all those
were fascinating to me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And real world
applications are crucial.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
One thing that's always fun
about being part of a software
platform is you think
you imagined everything
that people can do
with it, and then you
find someone outside that looks
at it completely differently,
and then they show you new
ways to use your platform.
And I don't know.
I always loved that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I agree, especially
with that podcast
that you guys did at
beginning of the year,
covering "Pokemon Go," and just
hearing some of the numbers,
in terms of what they
had achieved so far.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
At the time, people
had walked about 8.7
billion kilometers.
And what was it?
You could walk 200 times around
the Earth is the equivalence?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
For me, the coolest
part of that episode
was when Edward Wu was
talking about the impact
that "Pokemon Go"
had had in the world
and, specifically,
on his family.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: And he was
talking about how his dad had--
if I'm not mistaken--
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty
sure it was diabetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Yeah, diabetes.
So he had to take some
drugs, and walk around,
and everything.
And he didn't really want
to walk around that much.
And since "Pokemon
Go," he has been
walking so much that he was
actually taking less drugs.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: And
that kind of impact is--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Thinking
that your work in Google Cloud
Platform enables "Pokemon
Go" to help someone
with their diabetes--
I'm very happy about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
One of my favorite
stories is that story.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
All right.
Well, what you guys?
What are some of your favorites?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: So, for me, I'm
going to go with something
completely selfish.
So we launch many, many
products during the year.
And it is hard to keep up.
So when we had product
managers coming and explaining
what their product was,
it is really useful
for us and for our
audience, but, specifically,
for me because then I
can tell people about it.
And one of my favorite
episodes on this
was the one on Cloud Spanner.
To start with, because we had
the PM, Deepti Srivastava.
And she did an amazing job.
Also, especially,
she was about to have
a baby, which was amazing.
And we were like, really,
if you don't want to--
and she was like, yeah, yeah.
No, I'm going to make it.
It was like, OK, perfect.
So she did an amazing job.
And also, she was
able to tie it back
to while Spanner was an
internal thing at Google,
and how it went from
a project to something
Spanner as a
Service, internally,
and then how we make that into
something public, and Google
Cloud Spanner.
And that perspective
of the project
that allows you to see
not only the features,
but why it got to be the way
it is, is something that only
really product managers
or engineers that
have been working in the project
for a long time can give.
So that was an amazing
episode, for me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I thought that episode
was pretty great, too.
And she's so clear in the way
she explains it, especially
when she covers things
like the CAP theorem
and how that's
related to Spanner.
It was great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
That was really, really good.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mark, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I'll take a
different tack as well.
So we, technically,
started this back in 2016,
but we did three or four
episodes on SRE and SRE Culture
here, at Google, and outside.
So we had Paul Newson back
again, our SRE advocate.
He came back to talk
about SRE, after he'd
finished his rotation.
But then we also went to CRE--
so Customer Reliability
Engineering--
which is the more public
facing or the customer
facing side of the SRE culture
that we have here, at Google.
So we had Luke Stone on--
the director of Customer
Reliability Engineering--
to talk about the CRE platform.
We had William Bonnell
come from Home Depot.
He's the customer side.
Basically, they are
a company that uses
our CRE and their experience.
We got sort of
both sides of that.
I, personally, found
it really interesting
to learn more about how
we do Sire Reliability
Engineering, what does that
actually mean for our products,
when we start talking about
like service level objectives
and service level agreements.
And from a customer perspective,
if I'm building a product,
I need to think about,
how much uptime do
I have to have for this thing?
And does it correlate
with the uptime
that I'm getting from the
products that I'm using?
And how do those
things interrelate?
How do I deal with
failure, knowing
that failure is just something
that is always going to happen?
And how do I deal with
that, and postmortems,
and all the cool stuff that, I
think, comes along with that?
I found that really interesting,
like an almost philosophical,
technical discussion.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Any honorable mentions?
MARK MANDEL: Well, Melanie,
what's your favorite?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Actually, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, I
talked about the "Pokemon Go."
That was one of mine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Oh, interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
That was, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: I'm going
to go with an honorable
mention to Paul Wilson
because we have a category
on him, so we should.
He's the only person
that has a category.
MARK MANDEL: He's been on
like three of four times?
Three times?
Four times?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: I think it
would be three or four times.
So there's a category, Paul
Newson, on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
got to make some coats,
like they do with SNL, when
you've been on it for eight
times or something like that.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
A blazer.
MELANIE WARRICK: Like the
Steve Martin club or something.
So one question I have
for the two of you
I'm going to throw out
there-- we didn't really
plan on this one-- but what's
one of your favorite episodes
doing together?
What's one of those good
memories, back in the day?
Or funny moments or
funny experiences when
you were doing these podcasts.
MARK MANDEL: The messages
we were sending each other
when we were interviewing
Vint Cerf we're hilarious.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That was pretty amazing,
especially because I was staying
up late for this interview
because I was in Paris,
after doing Cloud Next Paris.
So I was destroyed--
Cloud Summit Paris.
I was destroyed.
He was waking up really early
because he was in Australia.
MARK MANDEL: It
was like 6:00 AM.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: And still, we
were able to keep
the energy and just
sincerely have a great time.
Yeah.
That's the kind of energy
that I'm missing now.
But there's also
from previous years--
when we interviewed John Wilkes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
That was a great interview.
So John Wilkes--
he's one of the guys
who wrote the paper on Borg,
which is the system that we
use internally.
It's kind of like Kubernetes--
the internal, Google
Kubernetes.
That interview was amazing also.
Partly because Marj
was incredibly excited
and it was kind of like
taking Mark to Disneyland.
MARK MANDEL: Disneyland, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: It
was very similar to that.
It was really, really good.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Do
you remember what
you were thinking when
you first started this,
like your very first episode?
And did you have
any sense of where
you were going to take
this or that this was
going to really hang in there?
How do you remember that?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We thought this was
going to be amazing.
We were very sure about that.
MELANIE WARRICK: You knew it?
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
GREG WILSON: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I was just
channeling my internal Vint
Cerf.
That's what I was doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yes, absolutely.
It was really interesting
because it really
felt like a personal
project more than--
it was really Mark and I. We're
going to make this happen.
And we started from
scratch with, basically,
just the OK from Greg.
But that was pretty much it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: We didn't
have the OK from marketing.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: We
didn't have the OK from anyone
else.
MARK MANDEL: We forgot to ask.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
We forgot to ask.
We just made it happen.
MARK MANDEL: Let's just do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
And then, at some point,
people were like,
wait, you know you need
to go through processes, right?
And we were like, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, Sure So from
very early on, it
felt like very,
very personal thing
that we were both really
into making it happen.
But at the same time, I was
slightly concerned about,
how we going to make these
happen every single week?
And by the end, I really
feel like we ended up--
like it just happens.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
GREG WILSON: Well,
the one thing I
want to bring up that a lot
of people may not know--
this is not your full time job.
All three of you are very full
time developer advocates out
on the road, creating
content, doing all the things.
And you happen to do a
podcast that we could easily
say is a full time job, but
you all, somehow, do it.
I don't know how you make
it happen, to be honest.
Now that I think about
it, I don't how you do it.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
think we should tell Greg.
No.
We won't tell you
the secret source.
It's fine.
GREG WILSON: OK.
That's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I think
that one of the secret sources
is now we have editors.
And that takes a lot of time of
our hands, which is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Actually, that's an
interesting point.
If you go back to
the beginning--
we started this, we did
everything, we did the editing,
we wrote the site, we did
all that stuff all ourselves.
And what's been
great is working here
and with the team and Greg.
And as it's grown in its success
and it's done really well,
more and more people
have come on board
to help us grow it further.
So the support has
been excellent.
I think that's probably
been the biggest indicator.
Yeah.
Actually, a funny story--
you were talking about how
you were like, oh, maybe,
don't do it weekly, that's
a concern and stuff.
And in the beginning,
we were like,
let's try this out,
and see how it goes,
and that kind of stuff.
And so, at one point--
you remember when you and I,
Francesc, we said, oh, maybe
we'll take August off.
We'll just take some time off.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Greg will
be fine with that.
It will be fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: That was fun.
MARK MANDEL: And I will never
forget the look on your face.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
A tear rolled down my check.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I was like, hey,
Greg, do you mind
if we just took a month off?
We were probably
six months to a year
into the podcast--
something like that.
And I was like, do you mind
if we just took a month off
and just had some time off?
And the color just
drained from your face.
And you were like, so is there
any way you could not do that?
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That
would be great.
Thanks.
GREG WILSON: I used
words like momentum.
But I really appreciate that
you guys stuck in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: That was when
we realized that,
all of a sudden,
it was not our personal
project anymore,
but people depended
on this to happen.
And I was like, oh, now
we need to make it happen.
GREG WILSON: Well,
you get addicted
to seeing those charts
go up, into the right.
And not to share too
many stats, but I
think it's super impressive.
I think total downloads
is approaching a million,
at this point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah.
GREG WILSON: We have to have
you back for that milestone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I'm
totally happy with that.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Anytime,
for a free lunch, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Well, a side note--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
It is Saturday morning
and I didn't have neither a
free breakfast nor a free lunch.
MARK MANDEL: We'll get there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
I'm just saying.
OK.
GREG WILSON: There's still time.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're slave drivers.
That's how it works.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So normally, we also do cool
things the week on the podcast.
I think this is probably
a wonderful opportunity
to sort of just take
a retrospective on GCP
and talk about what have been
your favorite announcements,
or new products, or just things
you've been up to here, at GCP.
Greg, I'll put you on the spot.
Come on.
You have pick, maybe,
one or two things.
What have been your favorites?
GREG WILSON: Gosh.
Well, I've been here
three and a half years.
I don't know.
There's so many launches
that have happened.
Spanner's one I was
especially excited about.
I have a pretty extensive
background in databases,
and have lived in the
world of sharded MySQL,
and trying to do
things like that.
And Spanner is an
amazing, easier path
for those type of worlds.
All of the EML stuff is
super exciting, to me.
I didn't have a lot
of knowledge in it.
I love that we have this
story from TensorFlow--
the very vibrant, open source
community-- to the EML APIs
with the pre-trained models, the
EML engine to go do your own.
And I think there's a
ton of potential there.
And I'm very excited about it.
Even some of the things
that are sometimes
not the shiny
objects, but things
that we're doing
with virtual machines
continues to excite me--
preemtible VMs are amazing.
You can get an incredible
amount of computing power
to a very low price,
as long as you just
account for the preemptibility
of it, which is not that hard.
Start times-- all that.
I don't know.
I continue to be
excited about all of it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm going to look
at you, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
I'm going to go with Go 1.8
on App Engine, just because--
now that I don't work at
Google, I can say it--
it took so long that
finally, when it happened,
I was like, yes, finally.
I know why it took so long.
And it totally makes sense.
There was a lot of engineering
effort going behind.
So in the future, it would
be much easier to go on 1,9,
go on .10.
But it took a long time.
And I feel like that was
a moment where I was like,
OK, yes, finally, I'm happy.
And the whole Go community,
all of a sudden, was like, oh,
yeah, Google actually cares
about App Engine, for real.
So I was very, very happy about
being able to say it publicly,
really.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
What's been your
favorite, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, more recently,
the fact that the
GPUs are cheaper.
That was definitely a
nice announcement to see.
I mean, for the research
community, in particular,
GPUs are extremely popular.
And that's a big deal.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I don't think anyone's going
to be surprised by my answer.
It's basically the
continual improvement
in the community and
basically everything
that's happening
around Kubernetes.
For a project that's been
around two, three years,
this year has seen
a huge skyrocket
in the amount of involvement
from outside sources,
the amount of investment
Google's put in.
The new features
that have come out,
they're just very exciting.
Yeah.
And this year, I've started
to get way more involved
with the project, too.
More out of necessity
than anything else.
GREG WILSON: I mean,
just the overall health
of that community.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, it's insane.
It's crazy.
GREG WILSON: And the tone of it.
It's just a fun
project to be part of.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, I think
we're getting close to time.
I know we want to
usually wrap up
with giving everybody
an opportunity
to do a little plugging.
So Francesc, anything
you want to share
before we close you out?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: So yeah.
I keep on doing JustForFunc.
So if you want to keep
on listening to my voice
regularly, I keep on
doing JustForFunc.
And I just recently
created a Patreon, which
is a new experience for me.
And people are now
giving me money.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I know.
It's weird.
But yeah.
Other than that, if you're
really curious about what I'm
doing, just find me on Twitter.
And I've been Tweeting about--
on Medium, too--
what I'm going to be
doing in the future and stuff.
And if you're curious
about machine learning
on source code, read it and
come talk to me because I'm
interested in talking to you.
MARK MANDEL: What's
your Twitter handle?
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Francesc.
GREG WILSON: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
F-R-A-N-C-E-S-C. There you go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Greg, you
got anything you want to plug?
GREG WILSON: Just this team.
Super proud of this team.
It's fun to be part of.
And I appreciate
you all inviting
me to be part of
this today, even
though I had to set an alarm
for a Saturday morning, which
felt very wrong.
But it was well worth it.
This is a lot of fun.
Do I get to come
on other ones or do
I have to wait two more years?
MELANIE WARRICK: You
have to wait two more.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
GREG WILSON: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We got a wait list,
we got a bouncer at the door.
GREG WILSON: I understand.
MARK MANDEL: Not
with those shoes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: I actually
want to add the fact that
on all of the episodes
that what we had, there was
a lot of the episodes that
were colleagues from our team.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: And
that was really amazing.
It really felt good to
have every single developer
advocate from the team--
or almost all of them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Almost.
MARK MANDEL: Almost.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Almost all of them.
GREG WILSON: Yeah.
We've been adding a lot lately.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
been hard to keep up.
GREG WILSON: There's been
quite a few, for sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: We got
to get a couple more in.
Mark, what about you?
MARK MANDEL: I have
nothing to plug.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nothing?
MARK MANDEL:
Everything's been great.
Actually, you know what?
You know what I have to plug?
Melanie, thank you so much
for joining me on the podcast.
GREG WILSON: Yes, absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Francesc, I'm
definitely going to miss you
and I do miss you, but Melanie,
it's a delight and a pleasure
to have you on with me now.
So I'm super excited to see
what 2018 has in store for us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me, too.
I'm definitely excited about
what we've got coming up.
There's a lot of content
that I want us to cover.
And we will
definitely cover GCP,
but we will also push in
to some other things that
are around machine learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: I
know some things are coming.
I'm very, very excited, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me, too.
All right.
Well, thanks, guys.
I know it was an early
morning, but now I
think it's time for us to
wrap up and get some food.
GREG WILSON: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Cool.
GREG WILSON: I brought
the credit card.
MELANIE WARRICK: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Thank you all.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's it.
That's our wrap up for the year.
it was fun to do that and we
had to do that on a Saturday
morning because of all the
conflicts that were going on
with everybody's schedule.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was a really good
chat, and good chance
to get together the old band,
and reminisce about what's
been happening in 2017.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Completely agree.
All right.
So question of the week--
Mark, what's one of
your highlights of 2017?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, so
many good moments.
Melanie joining
me on the podcast.
Clearly, that is a highlight.
While I definitely
miss Francesc,
it's wonderful to
have you on board now.
Another highlight
for me, though, I
want to mention is that I
started actively getting
involved with the
Kubernetes ecosystem.
That, for me, it was a
particular highlight.
I've got a pull request.
It's been merged
into Kubernetes.
It had happened sort
of late this year
that I started to do
some more work in there.
I've been talking about
Kubernetes for long time,
but I wanted to help get
the experience better.
SIG API Machinery is the
special interest group basically
around extending Kubernetes.
And so I have some
PRs and some friction
logs that I've
submitted to that for,
basically, just documentation,
getting started experiences--
like how do I get the developer
experience to be better?
And it's been a
really lovely way
to get involved
in the community.
My PRs, right now, are
not necessarily codes,
it's like READMEs and
putting extra docs
on things in the Go code--
really light touch
sort of stuff.
But it definitely
seems to be making
a difference, which is lovely.
So I'm just really getting
involved with that project
and getting started on it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Open source, man.
So cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Open
source is really good.
I'm a big fan.
MARK MANDEL: What about you?
What fun stuff do you think
has been particularly special
for you in 2017?
MELANIE WARRICK: In terms of
have 17, for me, definitely
a highlight is the fact
that I started with Google.
And the other
highlight is the fact
that I'm working with
you on the podcast,
although I know we've talked
about that so many times.
MARK MANDEL: You have
to say that, though.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I'm
feeling like, maybe, we're
forcing ourselves into
that that's a highlight
and this is a good thing.
Maybe this is
reverse psychology.
No, it's a good thing.
It's a good thing.
MARK MANDEL: As we keep
saying, then it must be true.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll
just keep saying it
and, eventually,
we'll feel that way.
No, it's good.
And I would say the other
highlight was end of last week,
at NIPS, one of the
workshops I was in--
the best speaker, for
me, was Haben Girma.
I hope I'm saying
her name right.
She is the first deaf, blind
graduate of Harvard Law School.
And she is out there, fighting
for disability rights.
And she gave the
most eloquent speech
on thinking about
accessibility in tech.
And one of the things, in
particular, that she really
wanted to stress was when you
are thinking about designing
technology, think about it
from this inclusion standpoint.
Don't think about
having different tech
for different types of people.
One tool for everybody.
And I really
appreciated her sharing
her perspective and kind of
getting that point across.
So if you haven't
heard of her, I
would highly recommend looking
her up and looking at talks
that she's given.
And that is my
highlight for 2017.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Melanie, thank you again
for joining me on
the podcast today
and for the end part of 2017.
I'm looking forward
to what 2018 is
going to bring for both of us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
We've already got a
lot of ideas of things
we want to talk about in the
new year, which I'm really
looking forward to.
But before we get
to that, of course,
I want to wish everybody
a good holiday.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Have a good break.
I hope everyone gets a nice
rest, eats lots of food,
has a great time.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll be back
after the new year, for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: We'll
be back, I think,
within the first
week or two, but have
a good holiday for you, Mark.
I hope you have a good
time with the family.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
And thanks to all
of our listeners
for enjoying our podcast in
2017 and listening to it.
We love having you listen, and
send us comments, and e-mails.
It's always appreciative when
we run into you in places
and also just hear
from you as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
That's all we got.
We'll hear and talk
to everybody in 2018.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]